we need to evaluate the limit
as x approaches infinity
of 4 x squared
minus
5 x
all of that over
1 minus 3 x squared so infinity is kind
of a strange number you can't just plug
in infinity and see what happens but if
you wanted to evaluate this limit what
you might try to do is just evaluate if
you want to find the limit as this
numerator approaches infinity you put in
really large numbers there you're going
to see that it approaches infinity that
the numerator approaches infinity as x
approaches infinity and if you put
really large numbers in the denominator
you're going to see that that also well
it not quite infinity 3x squared will
approach infinity but we're subtracting
it so if you subtract if you know some
non-infinite if you subtract infinity
from some non-infinite number is going
to be negative infinity so if you were
to just kind of evaluate it at infinity
the numerator you would get positive
infinity the denominator you would get
negative infinity you would get negative
infinity it's all right like this
negative infinity and that's one of the
indeterminate forms that l'hopital's
rule can be applied to and you're
probably saying hey sal why are we even
using l'hopital's rule i know how to do
this without l'hopital's rule and you
probably do or you should and we'll do
that in a second but i just want to show
you that laptop's rule also works for
this type of problems and i really just
want to show you an example that had a
po had a infinity over a negative or
positive infinity indeterminate form but
let's apply l'hopital's rule here so if
this limit exists or if the if the limit
of their derivatives exist then this
limit is going to be equal to
the limit
as x approaches infinity of the the
numerator the derivative of the
numerator so the derivative of the
numerator is the derivative of 4x
squared is
8x
minus 5
over derivative of the denominators well
derivative 1 is 0. derivative of
negative 3x squared is negative
6 x and once again when you when you
evaluated infinity the numerator is
going to approach infinity and the
denominator is approaching negative
infinity negative 6 times infinity is
negative infinity
so this is negative infinity so let's
apply l'hopital's rule again so
if the limit of these guys derivatives
exist or the rational function of the
derivative of this guy
divided by the derivative of that guy if
that exists then this limit's going to
be equal to the limit
as x approaches infinity
of arbitrarily arbitrary switch colors
derivative 8x minus 5 is just 8.
derivative of negative 6x is negative 6.
and this is just going to be and this is
just a constant here so it doesn't
matter what limit you're approaching
this is just going to equal this value
which is what if we put in if we put in
lowest common form or simplified form
it's 4 over negative 4 over 3.
negative 4 over 3. so this limit exists
this was an indeterminate form and the
limit of this derivative over this
this function's derivative over this
function's derivative exists so this
limit must also equal negative four over
three and by the same argument that
limit also must be equal to negative 4
over 3. and for those of you say hey we
already knew how to do this we could we
could just factor out an x squared you
are absolutely right and i'll show you
that right here
just to show you that you know it's not
the only you know l'hopital's rule isn't
the only game in town and frankly for
this type of problem i probably my first
reaction probably wouldn't have been to
use l'hopital's rule first you could
have said that that first limit so the
limit
as x approaches infinity of 4 x squared
minus 5 x
over 1 minus 3 x squared is equal to
the limit
as x approaches infinity let me draw a
little line here to show you that
this equal is that this is equal to that
not to this thing over here
this is equal to the limit as x
approaches infinity let's factor out an
x squared out of the numerator and the
denominator so you have an x squared
times
4
times 4 minus 5
over x right x squared times 5 over x is
going to be 5x
divided by let's factor out an x squared
out of the numerator so x squared times
1 over x squared
minus
3
and then these x squareds cancel out
so this is going to be equal to the
limit as x approaches infinity of
4 minus 5 over x over 1 over x squared
minus 3. and what's this going to be
equal to well as x approaches infinity 5
divided by infinity this term is going
to be 0. super duper infinitely large
denominator this is going to be 0
that is going to approach 0 and same
argument this right here is going to
approach 0. so all you're left with is
the 4 and the negative 3. so this is
going to be equal to negative or 4 over
a negative 3 or negative four thirds so
you didn't have to do use l'hopital's
rule for this problem